one thing I love about you is you talk
about you know having one at that
you get one life like make it make you a
lot of people you'll come out of school
and their first job technical you have
like people want to be you know promoted
immediately people want to do that like
what if I have to do the Millennial
seller coming to go out and kill it like
yo see our community what are you yeah I
mean look look I want to have the real
talk right which is like look when
people Raz on you guys they're wrong
right the wrong when they're like you're
just a kid Mulaney above the rock but
you're also wrong if you and not just
Millennials anybody if you expect them
but nobody cares for [ __ ] that you were
the captain of your lacrosse but [ __ ]
does that have to do with anything like
you're at zero like you're literally at
zero you're 22 years old and you're at
zero I mean like people tell me like
though this like dude that would mean
every number-one pick in every single
draft went on to become the best and I'm
like cool very glad that you had a beer
sorority Susan and that you've got real
leadership skills Mazel Tov now go
[ __ ] telecomix show me so my advice
for the kids since you position it that
way is shut your [ __ ] mouth and
execute for 18 months and then stick it
to everybody that's what I did I want to
remind all the kids I didn't say a
[ __ ] word to the world for first
[ __ ] ten years of my life
[Music]
put my head down I will deliver store
then I came out and said I built this
business that's a lot more fun I have no
interest in what you're gonna do
everybody's going to do every person
I've ever met told me there's none
[Music]
you